i gotta ask what's the first show where
you got that you were given that you
were like
really really excited for like like i'm
like when you realize oh i'm working on
this show
really this show was what was the first
time like superb
dragon ball of course of course i bet it
was when i was little i was
walking dragon ball at goku i was
emitting him
yeah and so i had
so so yeah dragon ball i had the chance
to work on it because my senpai i i
i was at the epico at this moment and i
had started as key animator
and uh yeah so we we skipped a lot of
years of uh graffinica while i was in
petrina
so when i was at yapiko
my senpai wanted to work on dragon ball
super the series
but so we had
our another senpai who had work on the
resurrection of
f and previous movie of dragon ball
super
okay and his name is shimizu
shimizu oh
he's the character designer of megalo
box oh
[ __ ] okay and he so he introduced us
to uh toei hi uh those french people
want to work on dragon ball
and so today uh uh met us and uh
okay so we have this episode you have a
vegeta and
goku who had to fight these
and not remember the name of the man
so someone's just like these guys want
to work on dragon ball and toys
literally like yeah sure
well he he uh we had a recommendation
yeah
our senpai okay so at first let's do
this reads
uh and if the series was good okay maybe
you can walk right yeah on the movie
because we and the movie wasn't
announced at this moment
right right and so okay let's uh let's
work
on the episode but when they sent us the
storyboard and the schedule
uh there was not a good match because uh
it was at the end of
december and most of the french people
was going back to
christmas christmas yeah and so ask
sorry can you we
can you give us another storyboard of an
episode
and oh okay um oh by the way how about
the movie
[Music]
uh sure just casually throw that isn't
that they tested you out on the movie
yeah oh my god what what a trial run
imagine that and it was the first time i
i'm drawing i was doing gengar on a
movie
oh my gosh so i had some pressure
because i'm pressure
yeah i pretty pressure because you know
that
dragon ball fans are can be
don't we we've talked about it before
we've talked about dragons
are the dragon balls the same in dragon
ball fans the same in japan like they
are the west or you talk about the west
i i don't know some people who can say
bad things
i think it's different when an animator
worked on the movie yeah i know
so i was a i have the had the pressure
but i was happy man i'm working on
dragon ball
and well yes it's cool and so when i was
doing
my drawings on dragon ball putting chad
i was sleeping at the schedule but i was
listening dragon ball and doing
it hyping yourself up yes and i had my
buddy uh media with showy
who was who we slept at the studio and
doing our dragon ball
oh my god